as nations around the world tried to
prevent the spread of coronavirus a side
effect of the illness is growing
discrimination of people based on race
ramie Inocencio reports this sign at
McDonald's in China said black people
are not allowed to enter africans have
been detained by police in the southern
city of Guangzhou the fear they're
spreading coronavirus some forced to
sleep on the street after getting
evicted from their homes in response
officials have said in effect that
racism does not exist in China dr. Adams
Badillo is one of the world's leading
experts on China Africa relations
Chinese Ministry of Foreign Affairs
there is no racism in China what do you
make of that there is this denial about
race and it's not just people with dark
skin who are targeted my holidays inside
eating lunch this mixed race family was
split apart at a restaurant you're no
more likely to carry the virus or be
responsible for the virus based on your
race ethnicity or national origin
cynthia toy is co executive director of
chinese for affirmative action we be
merely condemned that just in the way
that we condemn the kind of anti Asian
racism that we're experiencing here in
the United States in the US the number
of reported cases against Asian
Americans has been rising since March
more than 1700 reports have been filed
with women being targeted more than men
this attack in New York what an
asian-american woman was allegedly
targeted for not wearing a mask just one
in a string of racially driven incidents
taking place not just at home but around
the world it's really important to not
lose hope and to have faith in our
humanity for CBS this morning Saturday
rainy innocencio Tokyo